[Applause]
didn't think
this many people wanted to see a tick
tocker box bryce hall
didn't quite go the distance in his
fight against austin mcbroom
but hey at least both fighters walked
out of the ring with a big payday
it's over it's over ladies and gentlemen
austin mcbrown
on saturday the social media stars faced
off in a boxing match as part of social
gloves
battle of the platforms in miami and the
excitement began
long before they entered the ring with
both showcasing their intense physical
training
we got 25 we had 25 let's go let's go
and last month they erupted into an
all-out brawl
ladies and gentlemen it's going down
but everything came to a head over the
weekend as the stars squared off in the
exhibition boxing match
well it is the exact opposite
wow
over the course of the three rounds
austin landed over
twice as many blows than his competitor
he needs this eight count he needs it
needs to refocus and dig deep right here
by the end of the third round the
referee stepped in to declare the fight
a tko or technical knockout
[Applause]
in his post post-fight interview austin
gave thanks to his family and supporters
man to be honest i don't have words but
such amazing feeling you know i gotta
show love to my wife for supporting me
through this journey
my family my team and in a moment of
classy sportsmanship the winner also
paid tribute to his opponent
this man bryce hall is a strong ass
mother and i got to show him love
and everybody else on social media show
him love because they're not too many
people in this world that would get in
the ring and do what he did
shout out to you bro now one question
remains following the fight
how much did they earn from this
exhibition event
honestly that was rigged no i'm kidding
both bryce and austin claimed to have
signed
5 million contracts in addition to 4
of the pay-per-view sales but
unfortunately
everyone will need to wait a few weeks
before official figures are revealed
this is a crazy outcome to say the least
i didn't think
this many people wanted to see a tick
tocker box in the meantime bryce teased
another potential fight in his future
i'm not a boxer i'm not a fighter i've
never claimed to be a fighter
but next time hey we'll see good job
austin and on sunday bryce shared this
photo of him and austin on instagram
showing the tired fighters taking a shot
together poolside
[Music]
you